so I've now got an X value that taurah
spawns to here this is x equals 3 which
means that the base of my triangle here
is going to be 3 okay so that's great
I've got the base but I also need the
height where am I going to go to to find
out the height of this triangle there's
a couple of different ways how will I do
this any suggestions this time I'm not
just looking for a letter I'm looking
for where I'm getting it okay so I'm
substituting in yes this is an x value
remember x equals 3 where am I going to
sum it into well some of you said rows
me I see you've written some it into y
but keep in mind I've got two different
equations here y equals the blue one and
then y equals the red one and hopefully
most of you guys have realized okay the
red one is going to be much easier I
could do either because remember this is
an intersection point so this point this
one right here
it lives on both curves so I might as
well choose the one that's easier to me
so I'm gonna say when x equals 3y equals
3 as well cuz I'm just substituting it
into y equals x so now which it is yeah
I didn't mean to move that now I've got
coordinates yippee
I'm going to write that in 3 comma 3 so
we worked out that the base was 3 and
the height of this is also 3 so you can
see this diagram is not exactly to scale
or at least not vertically and
horizontally it's a bit of a stretch
here but now I'm done oh sorry that's
the mouse out of the way
is that on is that better there we go
Ishod happy now
sorry my mistake thank you for your
attention to detail okay so now I've got
a height I've got a a width a base I
should have said now I'm ready to
calculate this area so a1 I could have
worked it out with an integral but I
don't need to I can just say it's base
times height on to which is in this case
3 times 3 on to 9 on 2 that's going to
be 4 and 1/2 done so there's a 1 ok now
I need a 2 so this is to do with the
parabola right this is to do with y
equals 4 minus X
squared unknown now thankfully in this
case I've done half of the work I know
where my integral for this guy is going
to start it's going to start at x equals
three but now I need an endpoint and
that's this coordinate over here I don't
know what that's equal to how am I going
to find it how am I going to evaluate
this guy any takers
I'm looking for this value on the right
hand side okay fantastic I know well
done so to get this guy over here the
thing that's critical about it is it's
an x intercept of the parabola and the
way we find x-intercepts of all
different curves is to let y equal 0 so
I'm going to let y equal 0 for this blue
curve up here so instead of y equals 4
minus x squared or 9 I'm gonna do 0
equals 4 minus x squared or 9 so let's
have a go at that nice try a shot
it looks can be deceiving right so I'm
gonna write this to find x intercept y
equals 0 as Joanna has suggested so
remembering that this is the equation 4
minus x squared or 9 I'm gonna solve 4
minus x squared on 9 equals 0 okay so
I've deliberately crafted this equation
to give us some nice numbers I wonder if
your standard simplify this already if I
add x squared on 9 to both sides I'm
gonna get this I'm now gonna multiply 3
by 9 somewhat like how I did the other
time so this gives me 36 and now I have
two values here that solve this so I've
got plus or minus the square root of 36
which is of course 6 now just like
before I've got two values and I only
want one of them right only one is
relevant to me I'm gonna skip the
audience-participation for this bit
because you gave me the answer
previously how do I work out which one
it is you come back to your graph right
and this is on the positive side or the
x-axis so that gives me an x value of
x equals six right here okay so now I've
got my lower boundary it's three I've
got my upper boundary six so now I can
identify the integral this is the second
step right I can enter identify the
integral that will give me a two so
let's give that a go therefore a two is
going to be an integral from where to
where lower bound three upper bound six
what is the integrand the thing that
we're integrating it's the parabola
right four minus x squared on nine with
respect to X and then off you go so
here's what we'll do I'm going to give
you a 20-second head start to go ahead
and integrate this and evaluate at six
and then at three and then I'm going to
start putting my working there so you're
on the clock have a shot and then I'll
show you what the answer should turn out
to be off you go
and once you do get a value by the way
maybe don't post it but give us a thumbs
up if you're already there perhaps maybe
you were working ahead and you're
already too efficient for me don't spoil
the answer just yet just give us a
thumbs up when you are ready
[Laughter]
fantastic good I'm just gonna play
catch-up actually gave you way more than
15 seconds you're welcome
come on guys more than four of you come
on I gave you a massive head start and
I'm already there okay maybe you were to
be fair maybe you were catching up with
some of your notes this is what I've got
for a - all right so at this point I've
I'm always finished right I've done my I
have my sketch i I've drawl over it to
work out what was going on I identified
in the first case I could just use the
area of a triangle
okay Jason you can thumbs down but I'll
help you from here and then I identified
the integral that was related to a two
so I'm ready to go to combine and
conclude this I can say therefore zoom
back in the total area mm-hmm is I think
we say the first one was four and a half
right so it's gonna be four and a half
plus five which gives me nine and a half
square units like so dunsky
okay